comme c'est la première fois qu'on joue
à vous faire l'interview première fois
attention on ne touchera rien
c'est bien tous les cas il ya un truc
bien répéter c'est un budget par un look
génial ça c'est bien déjà obligé de
recommencer parce que souvent pour
commencer alors là il ya quelques
questions dont j'ai les réponses vous
n'avez pas intérêt à me raconter des
conneries
par exemple premier baiser
l'âge est le nom du garçon oui 13 ans
oui en voyant bravo menteuse
la première fois que vous avez fait
l'amour vous avez quel âge et lui quel
âge saison lui 34 bravo mais quel âge
aviez vous êtes allés avec votre maman
chez le gynécologue pour qu'il vous
donne la pilule qu'elle quel âge vous
aviez quel âge vous aviez lu que la
première fois attention j'ai toutes les
réponses
la première fois à troyes
à 4 non plus à 5 non plus non mais
attendez des gens qui fassent c'est pas
parce que vous êtes à ma droite et ils
sont toujours vous en arrière je la
connais les chiffres impairs sait jamais
première fois avec une fille ça dépend
donc rien on aimerait que vous avez fait
l'amour avec une fille
jamais encore découvrir sais pas
pourquoi pas dalli avait déjà eu une
expérience avec une fille comme on l'a
fait géraldine premier chagrin d'amour
j'ai pas vraiment eu de chagrin d'amour
non non vous êtes insensible aux noms à
bord non première cuite géraldine à la
première dont je me souvienne vraiment
ce soir du bac j'avais 17 ans ouais
comme si vous l'aviez raté où l'avion je
l'avais raté jusque là seul comprend
premier pétard 19 ans est en net retrait
tardif jack sur les sons émis entretemps
dernières volontés si vous deviez mourir
là maintenant tout de suite
et vous votre dernière volonté vous
deviez mourir là-bas benoît ça serai je
veux pas je vous parle